I guarantee that this NBA player eats
more Chipotle than you ever have male
Bridges claims he's been eating Chipotle
every single day for 10 whole years
Bridges has spent about $50,400 on the
Mexican fast food chain since 2013 I
thought it'd cost more than that until I
learned that chipotle gives him a
burrito card that gets him one free meal
a day obviously there are so many other
options but Bridges says it's too fire
and not have every single time so what's
on this fire order anyway he gets a bowl
with white rice no beans double chicken
medium and mild salsa corn and lettuce I
mean that's pretty healthy so I guess I
can see how this has been working for
him all these years